hello everyone and welcome back to
versus the show that takes two of
tinseltown's top talents and pits them
against each other to satiate our
competitive appetite it's really just
for fun but if you think nicole kidman
and laura dern aren't fans of
competition uh have you seen any of the
award shows in the last 30 years yeah
well it's probably because they were
there nominated for stuff the oscars the
golden globes the nfl mvp they're always
seemingly in the conversation when it's
trophy time now we get to celebrate
their respective career greatness on our
biggest stage
right are there we do other shows here
better than this no i don't know it's
this is my moment and that's not a big
little lie
in one corner we have laura dern who's
done everything in hollywood from
tussling with dinosaurs to wrestling
with david lynch's imagination in the
other corner is nicole kidman whose days
of thunder range from the music of
moulin rouge to the oceans of the dceu
both performers can do it all from tiny
art house indies to the biggest
blockbusters in this or any other galaxy
plus one of them has paddington's digits
on their cell phone here's how we'll
determine a winner
round one box office round two tomato
meter slash audience score round three
iconic characters round four memorable
moments and then we'll do a wild card
round that could involve penguins bats
or even little fockers one hails from
australia the other from los angeles and
while nicole kevin and laura dern have
individually forged careers that have
seen them and their characters span the
globe and into the far reaches of space
today they face off for the greatest
title of all versus champion sure awards
are nice and selling tickets is great
but today one of them will join the
ranks of the terminator mortal kombat
and jean-claude van damme who have also
won episodes of this show hey we should
do a battle of champions sometimes who
wouldn't want to see chucky take on the
cast of friends okay while production
figures that out it's time for kidman v
dern dawn of justice
have you ever played a character named
martha i think they have let's get it on
i can get you where you want to be
i can protect you just don't get ahead
of yourself you have a lot to learn i
can teach you round one box office
nicole kidman has recently been seen at
the movies sitting in a theater in ads
reminding us how special going out to
the flicks can be kidman and laura dern
have some experience in this matter
because folks have been coming out to
see them in droves since the early 1980s
these two tinseltown titans combined for
well over 8 billion dollars of total box
office and each has at least one movie
on their resume that raked in over a
billion bucks
while you all try to guess what those
flicks may be i'll start with nicole
kidman
one of kidman's early breaks on the
biggest of screens was 1989's dead calm
it solidified her reputation as a top
level actress if not yet a household
name but that movie only drew seven
million dollars in receipts however the
next year days of thunder vroomed to 157
million dollar worldwide take and kidman
was suddenly a hot property much like
her co-star in that movie some guy named
tom since nicole has done a wide variety
of films that have crossed the 100
million dollar line including animated
hits like happy feet live action family
friendly fair like paddington and
whatever category you put the golden
compass into it knocks 367 million
dollars she's also no stranger to the
world of comic book adaptations like
when she played dr chase meridian in
batman forever that movie hauled in over
300 million dollars and she's now
aquaman's mommy and that movie is also
her billion dollar generator grossing
1.1 billion dollars across the seven
seas laura dern may not have the comic
book movie resume of her combatant here
but she may not need it to win this
round you see she actually has two films
that earned at least a billion dollars
on the big screen and you know at least
one of them it involves a barbisol can
and a cartoon strand of dna oh and
there's dinosaurs yeah in the summer of
1993 jurassic park roared its way to
over a billion bucks and it was also the
proving ground that george lucas needed
to continue with his star wars prequel
films cut to almost 30 years later
george sold the star wars rights to
disney they made a very successful
sequel trilogy that included dern as
vice admiral holdo in the last jedi and
it serves as the highest grossing film
for either dern or kidman as it took in
1.3 billion dollars here on earth that
buys a lot of blue milk
okay that's an interesting joke whittle
[ __ ] the fault in our stars and
2019's little women were also huge hits
for laura dern as they combined for over
800 million dollars and i am sam
starring her alongside sean penn almost
got to 100 million landing at 92 million
dollars when we take a look at the total
career numbers laura dern easily
outpaces nicole kidman in terms of per
movie average of the box office thanks
to all those dinos and arctic ice fox
vult text things alara darn flick is
good for 152 million dollars per movie
as opposed to kidman's average of 108
million dollars okay so it's an easy win
for dern well not exactly you see while
laura has the average movie total
wrapped up nicole kidman's career
earnings hover around 5.2 billion
dollars a solid victory over dern's 3.8
billion we can certainly point to some
low multiplex receipts for either
performer even when the reviews were
stellar destroyer was a bold new look
for kidman yet the film couldn't get to
six million dollars in ticket sales and
durn's breakout roll blue velvet barely
got to 8 million back in 1986. and while
both have had plenty of hits since then
laura dern has only crossed that
all-important 100 million dollar line
five times but nicole kidman has done
that feat on an incredible 15 different
occasions it's a close race here as i
suspect the rest of the match will be
after all they're both so damn good in
big little lives have you all seen it
oh it's juicy stuff but in round one i'm
giving nicole kidman the nod for having
so many hits on one resume it's
australia one los angeles zero which
actually might be a fair fight
population wise right do not tell me to
calm down can
is that better round two tomato meter
slash audience score nope i was wrong
australia has a little under 25 million
total residents la has just 4 million
3.5 million of whom will be on the 405
as i head home so let's escape with more
movie math this time in terms of
critical and audience reception to the
bevy of hits courtesy of laura dern and
nicole kidman neither of whom could make
it here in person for a reason that i'm
going to say is traffic related it is a
zoo on the socal freeways laura dern has
come to play ball today and it shows on
her tomato meter report card she has 12
movies that all rate at least 90 percent
or above in the veggie garden and yes
that includes the last jedi and jurassic
park as well as the 100 perfect rambling
rose from 1991.
curiously kidman only has three films
above 90
led by paddington at 97 percent however
she recovers with a bunch of rock solid
freshness in the 80 range including the
awesome creep fest the others at 83
83 which is i'm guessing the age of her
uh daughter see the movie it's bonkers
kidman has a few flicks way south of
fresh as well including just go with it
the adam sandler vehicle with a dynamite
cameo from dan patrick at just 19
percent rotten that's tied with invasion
and her low bar was set at nine percent
for grace of monaco
nine percent is also the lowest rated
film for dern and that's little fockers
really seemed like everyone liked it
okay although now i think about it i
don't think i saw any of those meet the
parents sequels but in real life i'm
very well liked by the parents because
that's my demographic people my own age
not so much why don't we just stick with
the truth
kidman and durn both have slightly lower
tomato meter averages than their
legacies might indicate but lara is
fresh averaging 68 per movie meanwhile
nicole's average is a rotten but
respectable 56 percent which means she
will have some work to do to catch up
with the audience score well we got good
news at the top as lion is 91 and moulin
rouge is 89
improving upon their tomato meter number
bombshell is at 84 percent alongside the
hours and being the ricardo's is at 75
you know all those movies were mentioned
at the academy awards i think so maybe
it would help nicole kidman if there was
a round later today that involved a
fancy award gala
hmm
laura dern firmly stands her ground with
flicks like blue velvet and october sky
at 88
and i am sam at 86
which is weird why it's only 35 of the
tomato meter which wins it the coveted
comparison to man on fire another movie
shockingly low in the tomato meter and
super high on the audience score if we
look at two flicks that are rotten on
the audience score but did incredibly
well at theaters i would point to batman
forever's 32 percent and the last jedi's
42
alright fans good luck with that
change.org remake no recount necessary
here to declare a winner the audience
score tighten the race but laura dern
still comes out on top by that metric
averaging 61 fresh per movie to nicole
kidman's 54 percent rotten durn avenge
is the controversial call made by your
slightly inebriated host in round one as
she gets the win here and now the match
is tied at one a piece
round three iconic characters
the fair warning in this round we don't
have time and i don't have the vocal
cord endurance required to belt out all
of the amazing roles played by laura
dern and nicole kidman over their
sterling careers but wow do we have some
fun highlights to get to nicole kidman
was already a celebrated actress by the
time she was cast as satine in
baslerman's mount rouge but that film
showcased a new side of her that
elevated kidman into the pantheon of all
time greats it's a majestic portrayal
that was also well earned she sustained
injuries to her knee and ribs while
rehearsing the complex dance numbers
eyes wide shut didn't showcase dancing
as much as it did
you know it's a family-friendly show so
i'm gonna refrain from any of the jokes
that are exploding inside my brain right
now but kidman's alice is revealed to be
far more than just a pretty face she's a
few monologues that bring the house down
but it wasn't the first time we'd seen
nicole lean towards the dark side of
humanity she earned rave reviews when
she starred in to die for as star
obsessed suzanne her research for the
gus van zant flick included watching
tons of trashy tv shows and speaking in
an american accent the entire production
hey i can do both those things sometimes
even kidman didn't know how great she
could be for the hours she was convinced
that she should be playing the julianne
moore role but director stephen daldry
assured her that she was meant for
virginia woolf a successful award season
later i would say that was the right
decision
i guess a girl has to grow up sometime
long before dern had a smash hit with
jurassic park as dr ellie sadler she
made her mark in david lynch movies like
blue velvet and wild at heart
while blue velvet sandy can be seen as
pure of heart and someone who at her
court can believe in the good in life
wild at heart unleashed lula upon the
world a rebellious lover who hits the
road with nicholas cage she is and
seeing how she deals with the trauma of
her own past is emotionally wrenching
and utterly transfixing
i'll give a nod to dr sadler too after
all her combination of motherly
instincts scientific know-how and a
healthy pessimism towards dr john
hammond's theme park all united for a
performance so good we don't miss the
dinos that much when it's her human
character running the show
similarly her admiral holdo from the
original last jedi not the remake
conveys a rebellious nature that belies
her absolute allegiance to general leia
someone who knows a thing or two about
the hope that a rebellion can offer in a
fascinating revelation dern played the
role as someone who was somewhat force
sensitive although her character's fate
never allowed us the audience to explore
this angle maybe that's why she was so
willing to sacrifice herself her
unwavering confidence that there was
much more than just this one life to
live
i'm also giving tons of roses to laura
dern for her versatility she can play
everything from a young blind love
struck innocent in the tender story of
mask then she can pull off the stone
cold matter-of-fact divorce lawyer nora
who steals every one of her scenes in
marriage story imagine that black widow
and kylo ren yelled at each other for
two hours yet it's laura dern who
emerges as arguably the most memorable
give me a spin-off tv series with nora
and ray liotta's attorney character this
very second nicole kidman is so adept at
conveying multiple emotions with a
single look and it's worked for a wide
variety of directors it's astounding
that grace from mars von trier's
dogville is played by the same actress
who is charlotte in the paper boy who is
also the same person that played anna in
birth
that last one is from 2004 and while it
may not be as well known as some of her
other work the range of feelings on
display all at once is simply
overwhelming for all viewers there is
probably no wrong answer or clear winner
in this round but based on the entire
body of character work i'm going to lean
slightly towards nicole kidman just look
at her portrayal of lucille ball in
being the ricardo's did i need that
movie to be made nope never asked for it
but to see that transformation on the
heels of another disappearance into a
role like 2018's bombshell reminds us
all that when referencing nicole kidman
we're talking about one of the all-time
greats in hollywood history she gets the
point for round three and goes up two to
one
i hope you understand what you're doing
round four memorable moments
if you've had a moment of excitement or
apprehension or just flat out openly
wept in a movie theater in the last 30
years chances are it was at the hands of
nicole kidman or laura dern their
characters gave way to scenes and
sequences that thrilled us shook us to
our core and provided a new way to look
at our own lives plus did i mention that
we have a t-rex
nicole kidman has been so good at
conveying emotion for so long that
occasionally it's a great moment just to
watch her play against type like with
the absurd villainous fun she's having
in paddington or even in just go with it
those departures are earned because
we've seen her invest so much in
characters over the years regardless of
what their intentions may be recently
it's been a run of protective nurturing
characters like martha i i told you it
was coming and sophia coppola is the
beguiled or at least that's what colin
farrell thought the dinner scene where
he gets some intentionally bad mushrooms
plays out so well and kidman wears her
feelings on her sleeve with a devilish
intensity
she can actually be a protector just
witness her in lion where she's the
adoptive mother of a boy seeking out his
natural family kidman regaled a story in
which her sister attended a screening
and sat next to her weeping by the end
of the film that could have been any one
of us the lester scene birth also gave
us a close-up look at her greatness her
character is learning that her dead
husband has been reincarnated as a
ten-year-old boy and the tight shot of
her face for almost two unbroken minutes
showcases everything from love to loss
grief to excitement and it's a master
class in how to convey multiple emotions
at the same time
larder can portray power and
vulnerability with equal ease sometimes
in the same sequence when she's
recounting how a divorce generally goes
down with her client nicole in marriage
story she gives the strong backbone of a
woman who's built up a emotional callous
over her years in the courtroom yet she
does briefly give way to her inner soul
one that realizes the unjust nature of
such proceedings of course that can't
last too long and she locks it right
back up with a firm but that is the way
it is
david lynch films can often be a
mesmerizing trip giving the actors new
creative ways to express themselves
sandy's dream of robbins seen in blue
velvet speaks to her pure heart amid a
turbulent world and lula's wicked game
sequence is the single biggest reason
why chris isaac's tune is still so
memorable today even in blockbusters
like aquaman nicole kidman can lend a
tough yet tender presence to a scene and
make us feel real emotion or tear as is
the case in the others she just wants to
be a good albeit strict mother to her
kids as her world collapses around her
just look at the horror on her face when
she sees who her kids might really be
that's pretty much the same look i had
when seeing that movie opening weekend i
still have nightmares but when it comes
to a big time franchise no one nails a
moment like laura dern as amy lynn holdo
in the last jedi dern maximizes her
limited screen time by conveying tough
and tender simultaneously in a tense
scene that will require her to sacrifice
herself for the greater good of the
resistance we didn't even trust that she
was on our side like 15 minutes ago but
now we understand that her desire for
peace in the galaxy outranks all other
concerns including one for her own
safety
dinosaurs
eat man
woman inherits the earth all right
enough preamble let's get to the
breadwinner here the look on dr ellie
sadler's face when she first sees a
living breathing brontosaurus is one of
the great reaction shots in movie
history and in steven spielberg's genius
we see her look before witnessing what
she's beholding these magnificent
thought to be extinct creatures come
back to life it's hair on your arms
stand up good even after all these years
see
doing it right now after a few too many
close encounters with some other
dinosaurs ellie sucking up all her will
to limp back to safety is also
awe-inspiring both durn and kidman have
done so much in smaller films many of
them which earned award nominations so
my call has to come down to that one
moment that outshines all the others by
capturing exactly what pac theaters
across the globe were experiencing in
that summer of 93. it's the dino movie
that acts as a tiebreaker here giving dr
ellie said excuse me laura dern the win
in round four and it's all tied up two
to two as we head into the final round
and now it's time for the wild card
round awards yes i teased this was a
distinct possibility early in the show
and why not make award nominations and
wins the deciding factor look i can't do
a round like this in every episode you
really think awards would be the correct
way to judge van damme against seagal
while i have two performers of such
prestige today i intend to take full
advantage award shows they don't always
get it right like that time huwa won
over malcolm x for best actor or when
jethro tall upset metallica at the
grammys for wait for it best heavy metal
album yeah it really happened 1989. look
it up and we can extend our gala
glancing to the emmys as both kidman and
dern have taken home a trophy for the
same show big little lies y'all gotta
check it out it is such a riveting show
don't believe me ask meryl streep
nicole won outstanding lead actress for
the show in 2017 that same year durn won
outstanding supporting actress laura
dern has more emmy nominations to her
credit than nicole kidman including a
revolutionary turn in 1997 when she
played the love interest of ellen
degeneres on the famous coming out
episode it was a landmark moment in tv
history and ellen was in great hands
acting opposite such a pro like dern if
you want to go back and relive a
watershed moment it's the puppy episode
kevin and dern have both been steady
presences at the academy awards or is my
co-host of the rotten tomatoes wrong
podcast jacqueline coley calls the show
the super bowl finals series game it's a
big deal to a lot of folks and both
these actresses have won at the highest
level kidman won best actress in the
early 2000s for the hours dern recently
won best supporting actress for marriage
story laura dern earned her first oscar
nomination almost a decade before kidman
for rambling rose but since 2000 kidman
has been nominated five times her first
for moulin rouge and most recently this
past year for being the ricardo's all
told kidman has secured five nominations
with one win dern has three noms and a
win on her resume so while laura has the
better batting average it is actually an
honor just to be nominated and kidman
has seen her name as a finalist for a
major awards show a flabbergasting
254 times she won 106 of those meanwhile
laura dern has won 61 major awards with
109 total nominations so at the end of
the day it's just too many prizes and
accolades accrued by nicole kidman for
laura dern to keep up but let's not
forget how prolific durn has been she's
been in far less films than kidman yet
she was still able to maintain pace for
the entire duration of today's match-up
please don't do this every round was a
tough call but in the end it's nicole
kidman now winning the most prestigious
award in her illustrious career a
victory on versus a show that i'm sure
she's aware of you did it nikki
i probably shouldn't call her
congratulations miss kidman it's not
enough for me
it's just not it's not even close
this might be a fun duel to revisit
further on down the line as both
actresses have some real exciting stuff
on the horizon laura dern is returning
to the world of jurassic as dinosaurs
are running amok pretty much everywhere
in this summer's dominion and we'll see
nicole kidman in the next aquaman
adventure and those are just the big
tentpole projects that lean on talents
like dern and kidman for credibility i
am sure that we're gonna have plenty
more award-worthy performances to talk
about soon as well nicole kidman gets
the w today but that's just my silly
vote now it's your turn earth cast your
ballot by hitting me up on social media
with your take i'm at mark ellis live
and you can go ahead and follow us here
at rotten tomatoes for all the latest
movies tv and more that's it for us
today on versus and remember man creates
dinosaurs dinosaurs eat man woman
inherits the earth
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you